you
hi everyone is Jerry on November 24th
2012 magnus carlsen competed in a game
against the world in the second grand
chess festival held in Mexico City
Mexico for each of the moves the world
voted for one of three options that were
selected by grandmaster players and in
this game Carlsen on the white end
kicked off with efore and what was voted
on was the Sicilian c5 after Knight f3
d6 we're heading for an open Sicilian
with d4 cd19 Knight f6 Knight c3 and now
a6 indicating the night off and on move
six h3 what's also quite popular is
Bishop e3 and afteri five the knight
will make use of that be three square
however with h3 white is intending on g4
Bishop g2 ideas and a rerouting of this
knight to this f5 square so that's
exactly what we have after E 5 it's not
the knight going to be three but rather
e two Bishop e7 g 4 expanding and you'll
note that this is a strong support point
on f5 this Knight is on its way there
black castles Knight g3 black get some
development in connecting their knights
and after Knight f5 is now in a position
to just move this Knight out of the way
and it's quite timely this D pawn is now
defended and there's now pressure on
this efore point Bishop g2 development
defensive e4 more development on the
black side and now castles after b5 we
have a 3 this Knight does not want to be
kicked around and so rook c8 half open
file very logical moves and now f4
striking at this Center and has the
potential to enter the black territory
after this Knight moves this pond could
be expanding and that's exactly what
would have white establishing upon in
the black position so what follows is
Knight a4 which is a curious move to see
because you do run the risk well a
messy-looking
pawn structure but the idea here is to
eliminate this knight on c3 which is
better placed than this knight on c6
okay and you could reason this Knight is
applying pressure to this pond but
there's not really a way to put
additional pressure on e4 and if you
recognize the weakest point in the black
position the weakest Square d5 you
really want to try and get rid of a
knight that could potentially make use
of it so Knight a four addresses this
idea and although black has doubled a
pawns it now allows black to put
pressure on this B pun and well we're
not going to see this right away but the
potential to put pressure on the heart
of this white Queen side structure is
there and if pressure is placed on b2 it
may prove to be quite uncomfortable for
white to complete their Queen side
development so first things first we
have some expansion a lot of action
actually on the Kings side and a lot of
structural changes within these next few
moves and most of which are all forced
after g5 Knight d7 they takes Bishop
Queen recaptures and now f5 hitting that
bishop it only has one choice it reacts
counter tacking move hitting and hitting
the rook and abrooke just bumps up to f2
and black has to be very careful right
now because the main idea is to just rip
open this King side structure by making
this pawn on g7 flinch or in other words
trying to get in f6 which which is often
recognized as a giant thorn in one's
position so black does well to avoid
this by playing f6 and now we have g6 a
lot of tension going on with it with
these last couple of moves between the
pawns and the decision here now by black
is a great one because there's the
option of
taking the pun and after the recapture
working with this particular structure
or just playing h6 now what was decided
on was h6 and we'll see how this now
turns out to be a great inconvenience to
black because this pawn is just
priceless controlling these two flight
squares it will always present black a
problem for as long as there is one
heavy piece on the board there's the
potential for back ranked issues and
then we'll see that highlighted later on
but the other alternative well okay what
was played was h6 the other alternative
is to actually capture on g6 and at
first I thought that this would be a
mistake because what it now allows white
to do or so I thought
what it now allows white to do is play
Queen h5 and then make use of this h7
square but black fortunately would be in
time to meet that threat after H takes G
what we could have or what we should
have is rook F to D 8 which is vacating
f8 to meet a move such as Queen h5 width
Knight f8 and black is there just in the
nick of time to not only defend h7 but
the other idea is that it's putting
pressure on g6 and so things aren't now
as clean for white that's not to say
that this is um the best continuation
but just to highlight how black would be
defending should Queen h5 be played the
knight would make use of FA defend
against h7 and apply pressure to this
pond which runs the risk of just falling
not long off we could be seeing this
queenie 8 move and white is having to
find some accurate moves to be defending
against this and in the meantime there
could still be mounting pressure against
the like Queen side so we didn't have
this but this is a great turning point
in the game and that will often spring
about when we have structural changes so
h6 was played there is no potential now
to get to that h7 square with the Queen
so things now transition since the
kingside is locked
we're now transitioning to the Queen
side so Bishop III is played just
completing getting more pieces involved
and the other other idea that white
maybe could have gone with is b3 taking
note that all these squares are just
taken away from that light square bishop
and so the bishop will be kicked off of
it after either an immediate capture or
just going back right away let's say
takes takes the bishop kind of gets
kicked around for a bunch of moves here
a for Bishop c6 and after b4 white will
not be denied of getting to this nice
diagonal and development is really
really smooth if let's say King AJ in
anticipation of a queen playing to b3 we
just have really smooth the development
and the big thing here is that this pond
is still liability and these pawns are
perfectly healthy and soon enough can be
converted into a passed pawn so that was
another route our excuse me white could
have gone for as soon as h6 was played
to play b3 but we didn't have that
instead it was Bishop e3 9 c5
repositioning rook d2 it only came there
to meet that Bishop threat when it
played to that c4 square so now it's
functioning very well placing pressure
on d6 that rook gets involved to defend
Queen e1 so that these rooks can now
double Queen b7 and I was talking
earlier about the rook maybe putting
pressure on b2 but sure enough we could
also have that Queen playing the role
white avoids this not wanting to play a
very passive movie 1 is just not the way
to go can always be lets say kicked away
there's not a not a convenient way to
defend against b2 so the idea here is to
put pressure on c6 and the big thing
here is really all about the activity
Queen takes b2 is played in other words
because trying to hang on to let's say
this pawn on d6 just runs into some
trouble I mean black is on the defensive
in a great way what do you do after
something like Queen to f2 putting more
pressure on the night with still ideas
of penetrating into this back rank of
blacks it's very very difficult keep in
mind that a move such as Knight takes e5
3 what do you do about this pin there's
not a good solution if d5 you can
actually just take this Knight again
taking advantage of this back rank this
would be the best choice for black at
that point to immediately play the Queen
back to e8 but after the smoke clears
white is clearly just up a minor piece
so we wouldn't have Knight takes
in resort to a completely defensive
position I guess I guess you could play
queen c6 and after Queen f2 the knight
going backwards just to defend the pawn
but that's not really the way to play
the game so instead opting for activity
grabbing on b2 and is just a step away
from grabbing a3 and this pawn becomes
passed but there's some serious issues
again all really attributed to this pawn
being so deep in the black position
controlling these flight squares so rook
takes D rook takes D rook takes D and
now Queen to a3 this pawn is passed and
this Queen is indirectly observing that
rook on d6 Queen d2 re renewing this
idea of getting to the back rank
Knight d3 and interference move there's
a disconnect now between the Queen and
the rook the Queen is hitting the rook
and we have rook d7 an active probably
the most active Square for that rook
right now Bishop b5 hits the rook rook
d5 and now Knight to f4 hitting this
rook rook c5 is a cute me love just
interfering what black just a moment ago
played that night to d3 move interfering
with the Queen and rooks connection and
we have a similar thing going on right
now the rook is getting in the way of
the Queen coming back to maybe defend
not along this diagonal and of course if
rook takes we're just going to have this
mate once again everything is
highlighted
as soon as one of the pieces is no
longer around to watch over that
eighth-ranked why can simply exploit it
so after rook c5 we have rook e8 and
there are alternatives here there's many
different choices for the rook but with
each of them white is always slightly
better and if not winning there's maybe
some more resistance that could be put
up but what was chosen on this move 30
was rook to e8 and now this is really
going to crumble very fast
what white could have played what Magnus
could have played is an immediate c4
knowing that if let's say the bishop
plays to d7 y can actually go ahead and
grab it and allow a very appealing
looking queen takes bishop with check
giving you fork to the king and rook
that can just be met with King h2 and
there's no time to take the rook because
we would just have Czech followed by
matin 1 so there is just a little bit of
a long winded variation here after king
h2 there's not much you could do about
the the rook being threatened and also
this idea of bringing the rook to maybe
c7 or C 8 if Brooke f8 is tried rook c8
what to do about taking the rook and
giving mate here or just giving check
first and then taking the rook there's
not much you can do Knight g6
pawn takes Knight there's just a couple
checks that could be thrown in here and
eventually the King is going to find a
safe haven on this h5 square and this
idea of the back rank is still present
so what we do have instead of this c4
move immediately this is what could have
been played successfully but there is a
certain degree of calculation involved
knowing that you can't avoid let's say
that perpetual check instead of c4 we do
have rook to c7 getting back on that 7th
ranked Queen gives check King h2 in now
King to h8 there's not much that black
in
do right here there's the idea with King
H a is just to get off of this diagonal
so that it you know when the Queen if
the Queen does land on that diagonals
it's not going to come with check if for
example instead of the king going in the
corner if we had the pond just trying to
promote
well we snip the knight pawn takes
Bishop Queen gives check King in the
corner Queen f7 what do you do about the
pressure on g7 not much to do
rook g8 you just take the rook and then
you deliver matin to so one other
variation might be after this position
after King h2 excuse me Queen a to
preventing let's say c2 from coming
about
we could have Queen to d6 that's not to
say that this is the best move in this
position but just to highlight the
strength of this pond right here on g6
it's not just around to provide mate on
the back rank but there are tactics
involved against the g7 point as well if
for example a three just trying it again
to promote this is the tactic that we
would have rook takes Jean King takes G
Queen c7 King back the Queen gives check
and now this bishop starts to play a
role and this will be leading to me in a
couple so however you slice it after
Queen a one for sure black is completely
busted
so Queen a one King each to the King
gets off of this diagonal and what
follows is c4 this Bishop is killed and
what black tries is just to advance the
pone there's not much more that could be
done so Magnus grabs that Bishop Queen B
to pawn grabs on a6 and well this guy's
just a couple steps away and there's
just nothing to do for black at this
point what is tried as Queen takes Queen
Bishop takes Queen Knight e to and after
a calm rook c4 a two in rook to a4 this
pawn is lost this pawn remains past and
white is still up a piece black is dead
and at this point the world ends up
resigning to the world's number one
magnus carlsen so that's all for this
video as always I hope you got something
out of it take care bye